we all know the libs believe in
men being women and it recently was
women's History Month I guess it's still
women's History Month
and to celebrate women's History Month
ESPN decided to run a whole auditory
segment on the most important woman in
sports that would be of course William
Leah Thomas
in 2022 swimmer Leah Thomas became the
first transgender athlete to win an NCAA
division one championship by winning the
500 freestyle the Texas native competed
for three seasons on the men's swim team
at the University of Pennsylvania she
began position after her sophomore
season and after a gap year due to the
pandemic that forced to Ivy League to
cancel all sports Thomas made her debut
as a member of the women's league in
December 2021 the entrance is is not a
choice I didn't have any other choice
because
do not transition
needed amidst criticism from the
swimming community competitors and
teammates she said she holds her
persistence serves a larger purpose
people will say oh she just transitioned
and she would have an advantage
with I transitioned to be happy
you know I never said that will Thomas
only transitioned so that he could win
swimming races he was a very low ranked
male swimmer and then he became the
number one ranked female quote unquote
swimmer so maybe that played a role in
it probably did play some role in it but
no I think he transitioned more for the
reason that he says there he said to be
happy now it won't make him happy I
think social science is mostly bunk but
the surveys that we have on this show
that the transition does not actually
make people any happier than they were
beforehand and it it
is not the right thing to do because men
can't become women and women can't
become men and your body and soul are
united in a hylomorphic union and
everybody on Earth knew this until five
minutes ago and living according to
chopping up your body
and doing all sorts of weird nasty
things is not going to make anybody
happy really in the long run ever it
certainly won't lead to human
flourishing
uh
but I I have no doubt that he did it in
part because he's
just confused he's a confused guy he
said I had no choice of course you had a
choice
you didn't need to you could just be
normal you could just act normal and be
normal and you might have some weird
fantasies in your head but you can
either suppress them or sublimate those
fantasies or
indulge them in the privacy of your own
home but not pretend for public purposes
that you're a woman and then go into the
women's locker room and take your
clothing off and start start exposing
yourself to girls who don't want to see
that
you had that choice you just chose not
you chose to deny your own agency and
your own free will in the matter but
forget about will Thomas for a second
I had forgotten about women's history
month because I don't pay attention to
any of the
liturgical months on the the liturgical
calendar of liberalism I don't pay
attention to Black History Month I don't
pay attention to women's History Month I
don't pay attention to the now multiple
gay months I I have my own liturgical
calendar that I follow which is the
calendar of the church so we have months
to like you know to marry and
um you know at different uh liturgical
Feasts
that that do not celebrate liberalism
but this this proves my point that I
think this is a total vindication
of why we need to ignore all these
liberal months
Black History Month women's History
Month
because
women's history month we can now
conclude with certainty
is not about women
it's not
all the win The Women quote unquote who
have been lauded during women's History
Month
by the White House by ESPN by the
culture they're all men
so it has nothing to do with women it
has everything to do with liberalism and
leftism Black History Month
is only tangentially related to black
people
true ESPN doesn't run fawning profiles
of Rachel dollazole
they haven't they haven't yet embraced
trans-racialism but likewise you're not
going to see any fawning profiles of
Clarence Thomas you're not going to see
any fawning profiles of Thomas Soul
you're not going to see any following
profiles of Booker T Washington for that
matter you're not going to see any
following profiles of Candace Owens I
don't think no you're only going to see
a certain kind of black person and and
very often a manufactured leftist
caricature of a certain type of black
person these is not about black people
it's about liberalism
and leftism
so we should ignore all of that
ignore all of those
things how about for for the gay months
you're never going to see profiles of
of men who let's say they have some
desire and they just don't act on it
will Thomas says I had no choice but to
chop my body parts off and pretend to be
a woman you had it you could have not
done that you could have just been
normal you could have by that I mean you
could have acted in accord with the
norms and standards set by Society
through their use of right reason and
their deference to the wisdom of the
Ages which is a far better guide to
human flourishing than what some quack
doctors in the 60s decided it was was
best for for confused men which is to
mutilate themselves and live according
to a fantasy
could have just been normal
of course of course you have this but
you never see you you never see uh LGBT
History Month celebrating
d-transitioners Helena kirschner is not
going to be is not going to be
Walt heyer is not going to be celebrated
any of the multiple LGBT history months
so it's kind of funny it's it's dark but
it's kind of funny that will Thomas is
the woman of the month the woman of the
year for women's History Month on ESPN
sometimes it's a lot less funny there's
a video that went viral I had our
editors blur basically the whole thing
but you can get a little sense of it
anyway
a 13 year old drag queen a little boy
who was dressed up in sexual clothing to
look like a girl like a very sexualized
girl was just videotaped and went viral
dancing around at a club while a bunch
of pervert adults cheered him on
safely make out his Rings leather
stiletto heels and a leather kind of
dress skirt thing and is dancing around
in a very sexualized posture and then
these total freak perverts on the side
are cheering him on
their
what are they cheering on they're
cheering on a sexual performance of a 13
year old boy dressed in a tight leather
outfit
this isn't
well you know the slippery slope might
be slipping down this isn't some
conspiracy theory
idea there are there are Elite heados in
our culture and they have a lot of power
and you know you've got to talk to the
Illuminati and the rosicrucians and I
don't know some tinfoil hat stuff
it's on video
you're watching it
even the idea of an elite pedo ring
that's so Elite that they have I don't
know let's say their own private island
in the Caribbean and some of the most
notable wealthy powerful people on Earth
go to this island to do weird stuff with
very young underage people
that's not a crazy conspiracy theory we
have the court documents we have
pictures in some cases
that's
real that's happening
it reminds me of a line from Oren
McIntyre who's been on this show before
great political commentator
and he says guys it's not that
complicated they just want to ditto kids
it's a little more complicated than that
I do think there is an ideological
aspect of this whole weird sexual
movement that we're seeing I do think
that ultimately it it stems from the
political project of liberation of
liberalism that liberalism begins with
the idea of liberating yourself from
Dusty old conventions and liberating
yourself from superstition
non-scientific beliefs which we're told
today are allegedly superstitious
liberating yourself from the old
political order the asean regime now
we're going to live in a revolutionary
political order liberating yourself from
the moral order liberating yourself from
the family the fundamental political
institution ultimately
liberating yourself from yourself that's
what the transgender transition is about
the transgender transition is a ritual
suicide it's not a literal suicide but
it's a ritual figurative suicide
through which
a person kills himself he then refers to
the person that he has been literally as
a dead name
says that person is dead talks about
that person in the third person and in
the past tense and then out of that dead
person a new identity
is allegedly born through this ritual of
suicide because that is the ultimate
liberation of the self from the self the
the only
absurd illogical conclusion of that but
but it is the inexorable conclusion from
the the premises of liberalism is is
suicide that's that's the way out and
it's all terribly wrong and it's led to
a cultural suicide and a National
Suicide and that's where the logic leads
you to so I do think that's all there
but also all of that is preface to say
some of these people just want to diddle
kids
that's it those the guys there cheering
lusting after a 13 year old boy in in a
leather outfit and stilettos jiggling
around
they're just perverts
and they their desires need to be
suppressed by Society
I know that we live in the age of Love
Is Love and no no desire is ever to be
considered disordered or wrong or to be
repressed they need to be suppressed
yeah
there need to be laws against this there
need to be Norms against this we need to
round up the men who go to shows like
this and we need to lock them away in
institutions or prisons and we need to
tell other people that if they have any
desires that are in in any way even
close to resembling this sort of thing
they need to Tamp that down
stop stop doing it in public and stop
doing it in private just cut it out
sometimes things can be really simple
like that if you're part of the Hawaii
polloi here on YouTube get on over to
daily wire go to dailywire.com Knowles
use code Knowles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign